hi it's larry herb xbox live's Major
Nelson I have some great news the sep
tember update for xbox one has escaped
its designated month of sep tember and
is available right now in august go
check it out now what can you expect
let's take a look first up the media
player makes its official public debut
with the media player you can plug in a
USB 2.0 or 3.0 device and play your
music movies and pictures this includes
dozens of supported file formats and
we'll be adding more formats by the end
of this year including animated gifts
and MKV likewise support for network
DLNA playback will be added by the end
of the year as well next we have some
changes to the party system that I think
many of you will be happy with now the
party leader cannot only require invites
to join the party but can also remove
people from the party as well we've also
added a litany of updates to SmartGlass
you can now post status messages and
comments to your activity feed and game
clips you can view threaded message
conversations we've even added the
ability to record game clips directly
from smart glass plus Xbox one owners
can now set their console to boot to TV
that means if your console is set to
instant on it will boot directly to
television rather than the home screen
you'll find butta TV in the startup
settings another fan favorite request is
the ability to delete multiple clips at
once and upload now I love this feature
especially because I'll often record
multiple clips and then I'll edit them
together into a single montage now I can
easily clean up all the individual clips
I used to create the montage so only my
masterpiece remains
another feature I really appreciate is
the new bandwidth usage display you can
view this feature under network settings
it allows you to not only see how fast
your network is downloading content but
also lets you track your console data
usage for more information on the update
check out xbox wire at news xbox calm or
my blog at Major Nelson com thanks for
watching and I'll see you on xbox live